Dennis mcgrory you have been found
guilty of the rape and murder some 47
years ago in 1975 of Jackie Montgomery a
15 year old child and niece of your
former partner juicy Montgomery
I must now sentence you for these
abhorrent crimes
Jackie was found lying on the floor in
the ground floor living room of 119
offered Road London at about 2 15 a.m on
the 2nd of June 1975.
she had been fatally stabbed with a
knife through her heart and through her
stomach and liver
there had been an attempt to strangle
her with the cord of an iron which was
still wrapped around her neck
she had a burn on her leg
there was a scene of disarray
the phone was off the hook
a chair was overturned
there was a lock of pulled hair three
feet from her body close to her
discarded tights and knickers
her bloodstained diary with part of a
page ripped out of it bearing the dress
at which JC had recently been staying
also lay nearby
her skirt was pulled up as was her
jumper
she was on her period and a youth Santa
towel lay close to her body
she had clearly been murdered
and the circumstances strongly suggested
that her murder had been preceded by her
rape
but in 1975 the post-mortem did not
yield the evidence to justify such a
charge
you were the prime suspect for Jackie's
murder from the start
her aunt JC had recently left you due to
your violence towards her and you had
even more recently learned that she'd
started a sexual relationship with
another man and even worse than that he
was a close friend of yours
you were enraged and desperate to find
JC to inflict violence upon her
you are also willing to inflict violence
upon anyone to extract information as to
Jace's whereabouts
Jackie was just such a person and what
is more you had an unreciprocated sexual
interest in her
in interview you denied that you had any
sexual interest in Jackie consensual or
otherwise
you denied attending 119 offered Road
the previous day and you denied
murdering Jackie
in the light of the circumstantial
evidence against you you are charged
with Jackie's murder on the 15th of July
1975.
on the 26th of January 1976 when you
were 28 you stood trial at the central
criminal court before Mr Justice Melford
Stevenson and a jury for the murder of
Jackie
the close of the prosecution case which
was largely based on circumstantial
evidence the judge withdrew the case
from the jury and directed The Jury to
find you not guilty
you were therefore acquitted of the
murder
in the decades that followed you must
have thought that you had got away with
your hineous crimes and that you would
never face Justice you deserved for what
you had done
so how is it that your offending has
caught up with you
first the passage of the criminal
justice act 2003 which allows an
acquittal to be quashed and a defendant
retried in the event of new and
compelling evidence
and secondly advances in medical science
and the technique of DNA analysis which
did not exist in 1976
a cold case review I did identified that
upper and lower vaginal swabs have been
taken at the postmortem of Jackie and
those swabs had been retained for over
45 years
samples were taken from those swabs and
DNA analysis was performed
in relation to the upper vaginal sample
a mixed DNA profile was obtained that
indicated the presence of DNA from at
least two persons
and the results would be fully accounted
for by a mixture of DNA from Jackie and
yourself
relation to the lower vaginal swab it
makes DNA profile was obtained that
indicated the presence of DNA from at
least two persons possibly more
profile also indicated that the majority
of the DNA present had originated from
one male and one female
Jackie's DNA profile was represented
such that she could be the prominent
female contributor
your DNA was also represented such that
you could be the prominent male
contributor
a likelihood ratio assessment was done
in relation to the various samples
by way of example in relation to the
lower vaginal swab sample the forensic
scientist Mr Beaumont progressed the
interpretation based on the premise that
DNA was present in a sample from Jackie
and two other persons and had considered
the following alternative propositions
one DNA from Jackie you and one other
individual was present
and two DNA from Jackie and two
individuals was present but none of the
DNA had originated from you
based on the calculation performed the
findings will be at least one billion
that is one thousand million times more
likely if the first proposition was true
rather than if the second proposition
was true
and so it was that your acquittal was
quashed and you have stood trial for the
rape and murder of Jackie before this
jury on the entirety of the evidence
which included but was not limited to
the DNA evidence
you chose not to give evidence in your
own defense which was your right
but as a result you did not give
evidence in the trial to contradict or
undermine the evidence of the
prosecution of witnesses
I am sure that your reason for doing so
was that you didn't have an answer that
would have stood up to questioning not
least given your inconsistent
contemporary accounts and incredible
suggestions as to how you came by your
own injuries
nor were you able through Council to
explain away how DNA consistent with
your DNA profile came to be found inside
Jackie
the reality
as the jury has found by their verdicts
is that you raped Jackie depositing your
DNA in the process before murdering her
but why rape and then brutally murder a
15 year old child in her own home
I'm certain that you did so for two
reasons
firstly I'm sure that you had an
unreciplicated sexual interest in Jackie
the year before her death you had tried
it on with her while she was sunbathing
on the roof at Steen house trying to
grab and kiss her
you sought to downplay that in your
interview saying quotes we were just
mucking around
there was also an occasion when Jackie
was babysitting for your then partner
Josie
came in drunk and you tried to kiss
Jackie and put your hands up her skirt
most chillingly of all was the oral
evidence of Kathleen Montgomery senior
which I accept that you said to her and
Jackie that quotes you would like to
rape her and her sister Jackie
whilst taken in Jess she concluded that
you would do so if you could
as I and the jury are sure you went on
to do to Jackie
equally the evidence before the jury
which I accept is that you had been
violent towards JC Montgomery and used
to hit her which is why she left you
was testified to by JC itself and also
witnessed by Mary White whose red
evidence was that she saw you punch JC
on a number of occasions
which is also consistent with the red
evidence from Linda Devlin and David
Ballantine who reported that JC had told
them that you had beaten her in the past
even more disturbingly it was the red
evidence of James Reed and David
Ballentine that on a Sunday morning and
after Jackie had been murdered you
referred to jacey's relationship with
your friend and you said that you were
going to find JC and quote give her
Stripes as Reed says or quotes cut her
face off as Valentine says
I'm satisfied so I'm sure that you were
indeed violent to JC Montgomery in your
relationship and that on night Jackie
died you were looking for her having
found out that she was having an affair
with your friend
you were enraged and you were looking to
attack her and inflict violence upon her
and were willing to inflict violence on
Jackie in order to obtain details of her
whereabouts which is priced precisely
what you did
you attended one more nine offered road
that night
clear that there was a violent struggle
between you and Jackie
as I've already noted Furniture was
turned over the phone was off the hook
and there was a pulled lock of hair
it was a violent struggle you raped
Jackie and your violence culminated in
you murdering her literally stabbing her
to death
you raped Jackie a 15 year old child
because you had an unreciprocated sexual
interest in her carrying into effect
your previous threat to rape her
you meted out violence upon her during
the course of her ordeal
and this culminated in you repeatedly
stabbing her with a knife including
through her heart and also through her
diaphragm penetrating through her liver
and stomach
I have no doubt whatsoever that you
intended to kill her in your brutal
attack upon her
sadly and as the expert evidence
testified Jackie could have survived and
been capable of movement for between 1
and 10 minutes after suffering such
fatal wounds knowing that she was going
to die
you put Jackie through a horrific
violent and sustained ordeal in her own
home
a place where she was entitled to feel
safe
she must have been terrified as you
inflicted violence upon her and as the
realization dawned upon her as to what
you intended to do to her
and having gone through the ordeal of
being raped by you she would have
realized as you inflicted further and
increasing violence upon her including
with a knife that you intended to kill
her
how any man could inflict such sexual
and physical violence upon a 15 year old
child who had done them no harm Beggar's
belief
quite apart from the Fatal stab wounds
that brought about Jackie's death
you also inflicted considerable violence
upon jockey during the course of your
sustained attack upon her as evidenced
by the injuries found at the post-mortem
that were before the jury including
injuries to her head and mouth and a
strangulation mark on her neck
the attack upon her with both physical
and sexual
there was a Continuum of events and have
no doubt that your sexual conduct and
the violence leading to Jackie's death
was inextricably interwoven with the
sexual activity increasing the ordeal of
Jackie
and the depravity of her murder
this was on any view as the defense
accepts a murder involving sexual
conduct
aggravated by the fact that it was
murder involving sexual conduct with a
child
and as such the seriousness of your
offending is particularly high within
the meaning of schedule 21 to the
sentencing Act 2020.
with an appropriate starting point for a
minimum term for a murder committed
after the 18th of December 2003 of 30
years
I have to ask myself whether in fact
your murder of Jackie as a child not
only involves sexual conduct as it
undoubtedly did but whether it involved
a sexual motivation or a sadistic
motivation
if it did then the seriousness of your
offending would be exceptionally high
within the meaning of schedule 21 of the
sentencing Act 2020. and with the
appropriate starting point
at least for a murder committed after
the 18th of December 2003 of a whole
life order
had your unreciprocated sexual interest
in Jackie been the only reason for your
fatal violence that night I would have
concluded that the murder of this child
involved a sexual motivation as you
carried out your sexual fantasy to its
fatal conclusion
however I'm satisfied that another
motive was also in play in your actions
namely it's on the night in question you
were enraged and looking to attack JC
and inflict violence upon her and were
willing to inflict violence upon Jackie
in order to obtain details of her
whereabouts which is precisely what you
did
and which was also part of the Continuum
of events culminating in Jackie's murder
in such circumstances I step back from
concluding that the murder involved a
sexual motivation
as opposed to sexual conduct which it
undoubtedly did
I thought long and hard as to whether
your murder of Jackie as a child
involved a sadistic motivation
she was found with the cord of an iron
around her neck and with a grooved
bruise on one side of her neck
consistent with an attempt at
strangulation though the groove did not
go all the way around her neck
she also had a recent burn on her leg
that could have been caused by someone
placing a hot iron on her bare flesh
in circumstances where Jackie knew where
JC was and you were willing to do
whatever was necessary in an attempt to
extract from Jackie information as to
jacey's whereabouts there arises for
consideration the possibility of whether
you tortured her to extract or to
attempt to extract such information and
the question would arise in such
circumstances as to whether in
inflicting the associated pain and
suffering that you would have caused and
would have been aware of you derived
great and sadistic pleasure from that
however in circumstances where I cannot
be sure that the use of the chord
without was other than an attempt at
strangulation
or that you did indeed burn Jackie's leg
or that you did the acts you did with a
sadistic motivation I put such
possibilities out of my mind
what I am sure of
is that whilst fueled by alcohol and
driven by rage as well as lust for
Jackie
you raped her and thereafter took away
the life of a young girl who had her
whole life ahead of her
you did so to satisfy your own perverted
desires and at a time when you were
willing to inflict violence upon Jackie
for your own ends including to extract
information after juices whereabouts
from that moment on and far from
confessing to what you had done in the
cold light of day
you made up a [ __ ] and Bull story about
being jumped by four geezers allegedly
set upon you by Josie in an attempt to
explain away your injuries
including scratches consistent with
Jackie attempting to fight you off
you persevered in your denials even when
presented with the damning DNA evidence
against you and for which you have no
explanation because there is no innocent
or credible explanation for what was
found on the high and low vaginal swabs
profit through Council scenarios as to
possible sources of contamination
transferal presence which were as
fanciful as they were desperate and
which only had to be considered to be
dismissed
you made Witnesses including Josie go
through the ordeal of reliving the
events that they no doubt hoped were
behind them and through the ordeal of
being cross-examined and accused of
being Liars in relation to your sexual
interest in Jackie and your violence
meted out to JC
you have shown not one iota of remorse
or compassion for Jackie or Jackie's
family or for what you have done
we have heard the moving Victim Impact
statement from Kathy Montgomery Jackie's
sister who was only 13 months older than
Jackie when Jackie was murdered
we've heard that Jackie enjoyed all the
things 15 year old girls would enjoy
listening to pop music from the like of
Donny Osmond and David Cassidy
and she wanted a decent home life and
someone to love her
but you cut short that life and deprived
her of her life and of all the things
she'd hoped for in that life
it is clear that her death had a
devastating effect on her family
unsurprisingly your trial and the ordeal
through which you have placed those who
have given evidence has caused pain and
distress for the family as they have
Revisited painful memories of Jackie's
death
I can only hope that your conviction and
the sentence I pass will provide them
with some closure
safe in the knowledge that you have been
brought to Justice and will Hereafter
live out your days in prison whatever
minimum term I set
you would not have previous good
character before your rape and murder of
Jackie and you have offended further in
subsequent years albeit nothing as
serious as that for which you stand to
be sentenced
your subsequent offenses are for assault
occasionally actual bodily harm in 1977
and possessing an offensive weapon and
using violence to enter premises in
2009.
the facts of that latter offending in
2009 nearly 35 years on offers a glimpse
of your true personality
which has some chilling similarities
with events in 1975.
time would not appear to have mellowed
your personality
the facts are that you and your ex-wife
were arguing
you said that she had to choose between
you or her son
you said of the sun I'm going to
expletive kill him I don't care how long
I spend in prison
you went to a pub then returned home
drunk in the evening
forced your way into the house after
being told you were not welcome
after further argument you picked up a
kitchen knife the others ran outside
said to your stepson I'm going to kill
you again accompanied with expletives
chased your ex-wife and stepson into the
street with a knife in your hand
there is only one sentence that the law
allows to be passed for the offense of
murder
and that is a mandatory sentence of
imprisonment for life
I am however required to specify the
minimum term which must elapse before
you could be released on license
it will be open to me to impose a
determinant or an indeterminate sentence
in relation to the rape conviction to
run consecutive to the minimum term for
the life sentence
the maximum sentence for rape prior to
the 21st of December 1976 and now is
life imprisonment
any such sentence would have to be
consistent with the case of the crowned
Forbes 2016 ewca
crim1388 and applying current sentencing
guidance
however it's Common Ground the most
desirable approach is to impose a
minimum term in relation to the offense
of murder that properly reflects the
totality of your offending and to impose
no separate penalty in relation to your
rape conviction which is the cause I
will adopt
where a convicted murderer is sentenced
on or after the 18th of December 2003
for an offense that took place before
that date the court will set the minimum
term
the correct approach for the court to
take was made clear in the case of the
crown and Sullivan Gibbs Barry
Derek elner 2004 ewca crim1762.
and is set out in the criminal practice
Direction at Roman 7 sentencing n
the criminal practice Direction has not
been updated to change references to the
criminal justice act
2003 onto the sentencing act 2020 but
there is no material difference between
the two as far as this is concerned
the position is also set out in
paragraph 12 to the to the schedule 21
of the sentencing act which states
quotes 12 1. this paragraph applies
where the offense was committed before
the 18th of December 2003.
two if the court makes a minimum term
order the minimum term must in the
opinion of the Court be no greater than
the period which under the practice
followed by the Secretary of State
before December 2002 the secretary of
state would have been likely to notify
to the offender as the minimum period
which in the view of the secretary of
state would be served before the
prisoner's release on license
three the court may not make a whole
life order unless it's of the opinion
that under the practice followed by the
sexual State before December 2002 the
secretary of state would have been
likely to notify the prisoner that the
secretary of state did not intend that
the prisoner should ever be released on
license
the purpose of such an approach is to
ensure compliance with article 7.1 of
the European convention on human rights
that a heavier penalty shall not be
imposed than the one that was applicable
at the time the criminal offense was
committed
accordingly the following assessment is
to be undertaken
one determine the appropriate starting
point according to the sentencing act
2020 and then determine the minimum term
to impose having considered any
aggravating and mitigating features that
are not Incorporated in the sentencing
act minimum terms starting point
2 then determine what the decision of
the Home Secretary would have been by
applying the applicable letter and or
practice Direction
three
impose the minimum term determined at
two if it is lower than that in one
I will consider each of these matters in
turn
firstly the minimum term according to
schedule 21 of the sentencing Act
prosecution submit and the defense
concede that on the Juris verdicts the
events of murder involved quote sexual
conduct unquote
and therefore the offense is of
particularly High seriousness
and the appropriate starting point in
relation to the minimum term under the
sentencing act 2020 would be 30 years
I'm satisfied that the murder did indeed
involve sexual conduct for the reasons
that I've already given with there being
a very close temporal proximity between
the rape
murder
the deceased was 15 years of age at the
time and a child for the purposes of
schedule 21. see paragraph one of
schedule 21.
schedule 21 draws a distinction between
a murder of a child with a sexual
motivation
potentially a whole life order and a
murder with sexual conduct whether with
a child or not likely to be a 30-year
starting point
the fact that it is the murder of a
child with sexual conduct may be treated
as an aggravating feature if the age of
the child properly reflects such
aggravation
the prosecution submit however that it
was not a murder of a child done with
sexual motivation and further submit
that the use of the flex of the iron as
the ligature and potentially the ion
itself to burn would not amount to
sadistic motivation
the defense agree
I've set out my own reasons above as to
why I cannot be sure that this murder of
a child involves sexual or sadistic
motivation
it is not suggested and I do not
consider that a starting point of a
whole life order is appropriate in such
circumstances
I am satisfied that seriousness of the
offending was particularly high and that
the appropriate starting point minimum
term under schedule 21 is 30 years
it is then necessary to consider the
aggravating and mitigating features
I'm satisfied that there are a large
number of aggravating features not
implicit in the starting point which are
present in this case
firstly the murder and rape of Jackie
was committed in Jackie's own home where
she was entitled to feel safe
secondly Jackie was a vulnerable victim
by reason of a combination of her age
and the offending being committed at
night
thirdly there was the use of a weapon a
knife to commit the offenses
fourthly
there was very significant suffering
before death as evidenced by the scene
at 119 offered Road and the Continuum of
events with the facial injuries that
Jackie suffered the stabbed her back and
the use of the cord of the iron around
her neck which is self-inflicted an
injury
suffering such suffering goes beyond
that inherent in the offense is
concerned
fifthly the offending was committed
whilst you were intoxicated
and sixthly you destroyed the clothing
that you'd worn during the offending
for completeness and whilst I have no
doubt that you attended one more nine
offered road that night with an intent
to inflict violence on Jackie if
necessary I cannot be sure as to whether
either the rape or the murder as such
was premeditated
which would have been an additional
aggravating feature nor as to whether
you took the knife to the scene
the use of a knife as noted is in any
event an aggravating Factor
the aggravating features I've identified
justify a significant increase from a
30-year starting point
I then have to consider whether there
are any mitigating features which would
then justify a downward adjustment when
identifying the minimum term
there is precious little by way of
mitigation that is or can be Advanced on
your behalf
you're shown No Remorse Contrition or
insight into your offending
what is prayed in Aid is your age at 75
your poor health and a delay
as well as a lack of evidence of
premeditation
I sentence you on the basis I cannot be
sure that you're offending was
premeditated
I accept that your age poor health and
diminished life expectancy
and the prospect that you will die in
prison are factors to be taken into
account
but only in a limited way since they
must be balanced against the gravity of
your offending
the harm you have caused and the public
interest in setting appropriate
punishment for serious crimes
see the crown and clock 2017 ewca Crim
393 at paragraph 25.
I confirm that I'm well aware of and
have had careful regard to all the
medical conditions from which you suffer
and which will no doubt make your life
in prison more difficult as well as
reducing your life expectancy
I also bear in mind that the offending
took place many years ago
the prosecution has been Advanced with
due Expedition following the new and
compelling evidence
I make allowance for your age and
medical conditions and the fact that the
offending took place many years ago
with limited and sporadic subsequent
offending
but such allowance can only be limited
having regard to the overall and
principal purposes of sentencing in a
case as serious as this
see the Attorney General's reference
number 14 of 2015 2015 ewca crim949 at
paragraph 16 and the crown and H 2011
ewca Crim 2753
the mitigation Available to You
justifies a modest downward adjustment
to take account of such mitigation which
adjustment I make
taking into account the aggravating and
mitigating features you're offending the
appropriate minimum term assuming a
30-year starting point would be 35 years
secondly what would the home secretary's
determination have been
I turn then to determine what the
decision of the Home Secretary would
have been at the time by applying the
applicable guidance at that time
before 2002 minimum terms then often
referred to as tariffs or punitive terms
were set by the Home Secretary following
private recommendations from the trial
judge and the Lord chief justice
on the 10th of February 1997 a letter
was sent by Lord Bingham to all judges
who made recommendations as to the
appropriate term in murder cases
that letter is unreported but is set out
almost in full at paragraph 28 in the
crown and Sullivan
and is summarized in the criminal
practice Direction
that letter provided amongst other
matters as follows I quote
while I would not therefore wish to seek
to bind trial judges in any way I think
it may be helpful to outline my personal
approach
my current practice is to take 14 years
as the period actually to be served for
the quotes average unquote or quotes
normal and quotes or quotes
unexceptional murder
this is longer than the period brackets
12 years which Lord Lane took as his
Norm ten years ago
I take this higher Norm because I think
the level of sentence May in the past
with some reason have been considered
too low
I think the recommended level has risen
over the last decade
it is necessary to keep an eye for the
purposes of comparison on sentences for
other offenses such as the worst drug
offenses and I think the deliberate
taking of human life must continue to
carry a very heavy penalty
I regard a number of factors as capable
in appropriate cases of mitigating the
normal penalty
without seeking to be comprehensive I
would list the following factors one
youth
two and then bold and underline age
brackets where they're relevant to
physical capacity on release or the
likelihood of the defendant dying in
prison and bold and underline three
subnormality or mental abnormality four
provocation in a non-technical sense or
an excessive response to a personal
threat
five the absence of intention to kill
six build an underlying spontaneity and
lack of premeditation and build an
underlining beyond that necessary to
constitute the offense
EGA sudden response to family pressure
or too prolonged and eventually
unsupportable stress seven mercy killing
ate a plea of guilty or hard evidence of
remorse or contrition
without again seeking to be
comprehensive and then bold and
underline I would list the following
factors as likely to call for a sentence
more severe than the norm
two the killing of a child or a very old
or otherwise vulnerable victim
three evidence of sadism gratuitous
violence or sexual maltreatment
humiliation or degradation before The
Killing nine
the use of firearms or other dangerous
weapons whether carried for defensive or
offensive reasons
whilst a recommendation of a punitive
term longer than say 30 years will be
very rare indeed I do not think one
should set any upper limit
some crimes will certainly call for
terms very well in excess of the norm
and build an underlining and quote
brackets emphasis added
it will be seen therefore that the
letter advocated 14 years
as the quote's normal penalty for the
average normal or unexceptional murder
before taking aggravating and mitigating
factors into account
I should make clear that the emphasis
added above at paragraphs 2 3 and 9 is
agreed between the prosecution and the
defense as factors listed by Lord
Bingham which may apply in this case
I confirm I am satisfied that they do
apply in this case
I address Within These remarks the
mitigating features that apply I mean no
doubt whatsoever that you intended to
kill Jackie when you inflicted the Fatal
stab wounds
further guidance was issued in July 2000
which also referred to 14 years as a
starting point for adult murderers at
practice Direction
juveniles
murdered tariff
2001 weekly reports sorry 2001 one
weekly law reports one six five five
on the 31st of May 2002 the Lord chief
justice Henley down a practiced
direction for fixing the term for
offensive murder committed after that
date a practice statement life sentences
2002 to criminal appeal reports two
eight seven subsequently incorporated as
part of the Consolidated practice
Direction
the murder here was committed before the
31st of May 2002 and therefore that
practice direction does not apply
however it's clear that the practice
Direction was not intended to and did
not represent any change from the
content of the letter of the 10th of
February 1997.
whilst that practice direction did not
apply given the date of the murder under
consideration in that practice Direction
Lord Wolff chief justice stated amongst
other matters as follows quotes
49.10
cases falling within this starting point
brackets 12 years close brackets will
normally involve the killing of an adult
victim arising from a quarrel or loss of
temper between two people known to each
other
it will not have the characteristics
referred to in paragraph 49.13
exceptionally the starting point may be
reduced because of the sort of
circumstances described in the next
paragraph then in Brackets we've
emphasized the use of the word quotes
exceptionally unquote
presence following the advice of the
panel provides some support for the view
that the 12-year starting point is meant
to deal with less serious cases than
Lord bingham's 14 years
the word is there to avoid an offender
receiving credit twice for the same
mitigating factors which could happen
with the selection of a 12-year starting
point and then again in the form of a
further mitigating Factor
49.14 whichever starting point is
selected in a particular case it may be
appropriate for the trial judge to vary
the starting point upwards or downwards
to take account of aggravating or
mitigating factors which relate to
either the offense or the offender in a
particular case
49.19 a substantial upward adjustment
may be appropriate in the most serious
cases for example those involving a
substantial number of murders or if
there are several factors identified as
attracting the higher starting point
present
in suitable cases the result might even
be a minimum term of 30 years brackets
equivalent to 60 years which would offer
little or no hope of the offender's
eventual release
in cases of exceptional Gravity the
judge rather than setting a whole life
minimum term can state that there is no
minimum period which could properly be
set in that particular case
49.20
among the categories of case referred to
in paragraph 49.13 some offenses may be
especially grave these involve cases in
which the victim was performing his
duties as a prison officer at the time
of the crime or the offense was a
terrorist or sexual or sadistic murder
or involved a young child
in such a case a term of 20 years and
upwards could be appropriate
a further practice statement issued in
2004 bracket's mandatory life sentences
number two 2004 while weekly law reports
2551 describe Lord bingham's letter as
quote the best guide for how to sentence
old cases
in the crown and Sullivan at paragraph
29 Lord Wolf the Lord chief justice
stated quote Lord Bingham only
identified two periods a higher period
than 30 years which would only be
recommended in very rare cases and the
14 years Norm
he did not in relation to the 14 years
explain what was an average or normal or
unexceptional murder but an indication
of what he was including in those terms
is provided by his description of the
factors he identified as being capable
of mitigating and aggravating the normal
period in particular the reference
included in mitigating Factor 5 to the
absence of an intention to kill and in
mitigating factor six to lack of
premeditation suggests that the 14-year
period was intended to cover more
serious murders since if intentional and
premeditated murders were not included
five and six would be inappropriate
mitigating factors end quote
I bear in mind that Lord Bingham
referred to his starting point for the
quotes average murder unquote as longer
than the period that Lord Lane took as
his Norm 10 years earlier
so in 1987 albeit Lord Lane had been law
chief justice since 1980.
it appears therefore in the absence of
any further guidance that a lower
starting point in the 1970s of 12 years
would have been adopted for a quote's
average murder before having regard to
aggravating or mitigating factors
however it is Common Ground between the
prosecution and the defense that this
was not an average murder
the defense conceding that to be so
given that there was a rape and having
regard to the aggravating factors that
have been identified
nor I am satisfied can it be regarded as
a normal or unexceptional murder if
there is such a thing
it is again common ground that in the
words of the defense and I quote plainly
a substantial increase from there
brackets of 12-year starting point in
the 1970s is required end quote having
regard to the rape and to reflect the
aggravating factors identified
ultimately the defense are met that an
appropriate minimum term had you been
sentenced in the 1970s is in the order
of 18 to 20 years
in this regard the defense admit that I
quote very few of the aggravating
factors listed in Lord bingham's letter
are present end quote
for its part the prosecution submit that
far from being an average or normal
murder the murder can be regarded as
exceptionally serious albeit not within
the meaning of that term in schedule 21
to the sentencing Act 2020.
nursing a far longer term than an
average or normal murder and in excess
of 20 years
a prosecution also submits that it would
be open to the court to conclude that
this is one of those rare cases where
the Home Secretary would have imposed a
term of around 30 years
the consideration of the minimum term is
in one sense likely to be academic
whatever the minimum term and whether as
advocated by the defense or the
prosecution or as passed by me
in all probability you will die in
prison given your current age
however I must be true to the applicable
sentencing principles and the
seriousness of your offending in fixing
the minimum term
I cannot accept the defense submission
that very few of the aggravating factors
listed in Lord bingham's letter are
present
on the contrary no less than three of
those factors are present as was in fact
Common Ground namely the killing of a
child
evidence of sexual maltreatment and of a
child at that and the use of a knife
the circumstances of your offending were
also humiliating and degrading
each of these factors would be likely to
quote call for a sentence more severe
than the norm End quotes but here a
number apply and cumulatively they call
for a sentence very substantially more
severe than the norm or to put it
another way a very substantial increase
from the starting point
furthermore Lord Bingham made clear as
is obviously right that these factors
are not comprehensive
I consider all the additional
aggravating factors identified above
also justify and require a sentence
substantially more severe than the norm
straight require a further increase from
the starting point
specifically the offending being
committed in Jackie's own home which was
entitled to feel safe
a vulnerability with the offending being
committed at night
that she suffered very significant
suffering before her death
that you committed the offending whilst
intoxicated
and that you destroyed clothing that
you'd warned during the offending to
conceal your crimes the evidence being
that your clothing would have been
heavily blood-stained as was Jackie's
one has to stand back and look at the
Continuum of events and the totality of
your offending that night
this was the brutal rape and murder of a
15 year old child in her own home at
night
who was put through a sustained ordeal
including a physical struggle
physical violence
sexual conduct including pulling up her
top and skirt removing her sanitary
towel and raping her an attempt at
strangulation with the cord of an iron
and culminating and you knifing her to
her back through her heart and through
her stomach and liver
I'm in no doubt whatsoever that such
offending in the 1970s applying Lord
bingham's Guidance with the brutal rape
and murder of a child in her own home
and in the further aggravating
circumstances I've identified whilst
also recognizing your available
mitigation such as it is calls for a
sentence very substantially more severe
than the norm straight the starting
point and one that was in excess of the
18 to 20 years advocated on your behalf
such a sentence would not reflect the
seriousness of your offending which was
particularly High
I consider having regard to the
aggravating and mitigating features
you're offending as already addressed
and having full and careful regard to
totality that you're offending was so
serious that in the 1970s a minimum term
of no less than 26 years was justified
and required for what was the brutal
rape and murder of a 15 year old child
in her own home an abhorrent occurrence
that would have been regarded as
justifying and requiring such a sentence
I'm satisfied with any lesser sentence
would not have reflected the seriousness
of your offending and would not have
reflected the recommendation of a trial
judge or the decision of the Home
Secretary in the 1970s
I turn to consider whether the totality
of your offending was in fact so serious
as to require an even greater minimum
term or is one of those very rare cases
where a punitive term of some 30 years
or more is Justified there being no
upper limit
I've pulled back from reaching such a
conclusion for the following reasons
first sentences of such lengths were
very rare and would have been reserved
for exceptionally serious cases
and sadly hinia says your crimes were it
is possible to envisage residual cases
of even greater and exceptional
seriousness so as to require such
sentences
secondly it appears that in the 1970s
the starting point was lower than in the
1980s and I consider that is a further
reason why it's likely that in the 1970s
a minimum term for such serious
offending as yours was not less than 26
years would not have been higher
thirdly in reaching the conclusions I
have I've had careful regard not only to
the principles in the crown and Sullivan
but also the cases and Associated
sentences there under consideration
fourthly I've taken the view that if
there is any doubt in my mind as to the
minimum term that would have been
recommended in the 1970s I should err on
the side of caution so as to ensure that
no heavier penalty is imposed than the
one that would have been applicable at
the time so as to be compliant with
article 7.1 of the ehcr
accordingly I am satisfied and fined
that the period which under the practice
followed by the Home Secretary before
December 2002 the Home Secretary would
have been likely to notify to you as the
minimum term which in the view of the
Home Secretary should be served before
your release on license is 26 years
that being lower than the minimum term
I've identified under the sentencing act
2020 had your offending occurred after
the 18th of December 2003 I set the
minimum term on count one in accordance
with the principles in the crown and
Sullivan and schedule 21 paragraph 12 of
the sentencing act 2020 as 26 years
subject consideration of the time you
have spent on remand
with your time on remand in relation to
the first trial would automatically be
credited or not about which there is
some debate I consider it appropriate to
give you credit for the overall time you
have spent on remand in setting the
minimum term an approach to which the
prosecution do not object and which I am
told amounts to 207 days between the
11th of July 1975 and the 2nd of
February 1976 and 32 days between the
12th of December 2022 to the 12th of
January 2023 a total of
239 days
accordingly the sentence I pass on count
one is life imprisonment with a minimum
term of 25 years and 126 days
it is important to emphasize so that you
and the public can understand the
position but the minimum term is just
that
a minimum term that cannot be reduced in
any way
after it is served there is no guarantee
that you'll be released at that time or
at any particular time thereafter
then only if the parole board decide
that you are fit to be released that you
would be released after which you would
remain subject to license for the
remainder of your life it is in these
ways that a life sentence protects the
public for the future
the reality however is that you will in
all probability die in prison before the
minimum term is reached
in relation to count to rape and having
already taken that offending into
account in setting the minimum term in
respect of count 1 based on the totality
if you're offending I impose no separate
penalty and respect of count two
as a consequence of your conviction for
rape if you're ever released you'll be
subject to notification requirements to
the police and you will or maybe barred
from particular regulated activities the
victim's surcharge applies in this case
the order can be drawn up accordingly in
the appropriate amount
that concludes my sentencing remarks
which will be available in writing
afterwards